all right so we have to remember h5 okay
oh I got it high five
oh I see oh that's guys what you're
trying to do they're trying to figure
out a mnemonic device okay high fives
came out in the 70s that's when they
were invented that's a seven yeah
there's two of us so so if I subtract
two from seven that's five okay great so
you got it so then there's five more
groups
why are you going on oh no you're gonna
love this this is fun for me cuz it's a
puzzle no no puzzle okay five five major
food groups there's meat vegetables
grain dairy and fruits of my favorite
fruit is pineapple but you know that
we've got it already
pineapple comes from Hawaii okay and oh
my favorite current show is Hawaii
five-o Hawaii five-o okay so that's it
done we're done - Scott Scott Caan is
the song y5o we're really talking about
Skye's father is James Caan who's one of
the five major stars what's wrong the
one of the five major huge stars right
of the Godfather movies
so it's Pacino Brando and the white ball
and Keaton yes thank you and it's easy
to remember her name cause her name is
the same last name as luster Keaton and
Michael Keaton oh we're just going for
comedians and when you laugh you're say
ha stop stop stop stop
let's see what you're doing you're
overcomplicating the whole thing we
already had it you just you just you
just making it more difficult just like
you do everything I left my phone in the
car which is wait hold up DAP no no it
was handshake no I got it I got it I got
it
aha Buster Keaton and Michael Keaton say
my name is Diane Keaton is one of the
five huge stars and on the Godfather
movies Isaac Newton Brando Duvall Pacino
and James Caan Oh who's the father Scott
Caan is the star five o hawai II
pineapple pineapple rooms in the five
major mansion
two of us five plus two is seven plus
seven
you